depuis quelques jours une oeuvre exposée
au Palais de Tokyo suscite une vive
polémique au sein même de l'Assemblée
nationale le tableau de Myriam Kahn qui
présente aux yeux de tous une scène de
pédocriminalité
par d'autres députés de gauche ce
tableau où l'on voit une personne
pratiquée de force une fellation
représenterait un enfant mais la
ministre de la Culture interpellé à ce
sujet a tenu à défendre l'artiste et à
livrer une autre version pour elle c'est
une dénonciation des crimes de guerre
voilà ce qu'elle dit ce ne sont pas des
enfants qui sont représentés
si des panneaux d'avertissement ont bien
été mis en place à l'entrée du bâtiment
pour prévenir les âmes sensibles de
nombreuses personnes souhaitent
aujourd'hui aller encore plus loin je
demande solennellement à la ministre de
la Culture que ce tableau soit décroché
à l'exposition d'une œuvre fait scandale
doit-elle être retirée
avant montrez-nous l’œuvre il nous
montre flouté cette bande de repas
n'importe quoi on la voit partout
c'est la chaîne il dit non on peut pas
montrer là mes frères tout le monde la
voit à l'oeuvre dites pas n'importe quoi
c'est sympa
justement
vous êtes là non mais je vous jure que
c'est vrai non mais sans déconner on
marche sur la tête donc vous cherchez
l'oeuvre et vous me la mettez oui bene
ma tante en deux minutes parce que donc
on va voir déjà ce qu'a dit la députée
parce que donc on l'a vu Caroline
Parmentier député du rassemblement
national et c'était rendu au Palais de
Tokyo il dénoncé le tableau voilà donc
elle a diffusé sur les réseaux vous avez
vu ça et il y a elle a aussi de porter
le débat à l'Assemblée nationale en
interpellant la ministre de la Culture
Rima Abdul malade ce tableau représente
un enfant à genoux ligoté les mains dans
le dos forcer à une fellation par un
adulte rien ne justifie l'exposition
d'une telle oeuvre pas même le prétexte
de la dénonciation des crimes de guerre
en tant que membre de la commission des
affaires culturelles en tant que membre
de la délégation au droit des enfants
mais surtout en tant que femme et en
tant que mère je vous demande madame la
ministre si l'exposition de ce genre de
tableau sera l'un des marqueurs de votre
mandat un glissement vers la
démocratisation et l'acceptation de ce
type d'oeuvre et si ce n'est pas le cas
je vous le demande solennellement quand
ce tableau va-t-il être décroché
donc alors
a répondu la ministre regardez ce
qu'elle a répondu
d'habitude c'est un tableau d'une
artiste suisse Myriam Khan son
exposition au Palais de Tokyo artiste de
73 ans qui depuis 40 ans
documente et dénonce les horreurs de la
guerre
c'est son intention vous êtes allé faire
votre coup de com et filmer ce tableau
mais est-ce que vous avez vu l'ensemble
de l'exposition voilà ce qu'elle dit ce
ne sont pas des enfants qui sont
représentés ce tableau traite de la
façon dont la sexualité est utilisée
comme arme de guerre comme crime contre
l'humanité vous avez toute liberté
d'interpréter l'oeuvre comme vous voulez
ce n'est ni à une ministre ni à une
parlementaire en revanche de qualifier
une infraction pénale c'est le rôle de
la justice
[Musique]
on peut pas diffuser ce tableau à cette
heure-ci n'importe quoi comme si tu
montrais pas l'origine de courber
ou alors
même la ministre la défendu là donc oui
ou pas donc voilà qu'est-ce que vous
dites moi je fais pour le retraite plus
simple décrochage du tableau
ça craint laissez-moi finir ça crée un
immense malaise qui a flouté mais vous
montrer le tableau ça craint un immense
malaise alors l'artiste et j'ai vu le
tableau il est très très chaud
c'est pour dénoncer mais ça je ne sais
même pas si c'est vrai peut-être dans
son esprit mais quand on le voit malgré
les avertissements bordel c'est trop
choquant à partir du moment où les gens
sont choqués comme moi comme la député
comme des tas de gens il faut retirer ce
tableau s'il est possible oui mais peu
importe c'est une œuvre mais faut-il
l'enlever ou pas il est possible que ce
soit un an il est possible que ce soit
un enfant en train de faire une
fellation honteux ça c'est honteux donc
il faut le décrocher on ne peut même pas
discuter de la liberté artistique de ce
que vous voulez c'est extrêmement
choquant
la pédophilie c'est un sujet extrêmement
sérieux extrêmement grave qui détruit
des vies donc décrocher cette croûte
infâme et ignoble mais vous êtes dingue
on va voir
les régimes et les régimes toutes
motorisés pour décider effectivement ce
qui était une oeuvre et ceux qui n'était
pas les livres qu'il fallait brûler et
ceux qui fallait pas brûler à une œuvre
c'est une œuvre c'est une la pas compris
peut-être il faut que tu rebosses un
petit peu tes cours et que tu ailles à
l'école il y a des choses à comprendre
il y a des symboles qui ont échappé
c'est pas de la pédophilie elle est en
train de faire
rien compris on en a marre de ces gens
qui ont la carte c'est comme les trucs
sinon on fait ce dessin là on le montre
on fait un truc marrant sur ça tout le
monde va nous on va dire donc demain
restez avec nous on va voir dans un
instant parce que si on met pas le
tableau là les gars déjà ça veut dire si
la chaîne vous pouvez me contacter les
gars c'est qu'il y a un problème ça peut
tout dire exactement le jour on enlève
la c'est la fin de la démocratie
le tableau donc ils disent n'importe
quoi mais le tableau il faut le voir
donc on va voir avec la chaîne si la
chaîne veut pas qu'on monte le tableau
c'est qu'il y a un vrai problème vous
allez voir ceux qui l'ont pas vu vous
allez comprendre c'est quand même un
truc de fou incroyable il m'a dit
qu'elle est plus sur notre tête sur des
tableaux comme ça que tout le monde va
voir si vous voulez
non non non
c'est catastrophique
voilà j'ai des textos de partout de gens
qui me disent c'est inadmissible de
laisser ça et la ministre
voilà la ministre qui dit qu'elle est
pour cette œuvre et qu'elle a défendu on
va revoir remettez-moi ce qu'elle a dit
la liste
c'est un tableau d'une artiste suisse
Myriam Cannes son exposition au Palais
de Tokyo artiste de 73 ans qui depuis 40
ans
documents et dénonce les horreurs de la
guerre
c'est son intention vous êtes allé faire
votre coup de com et filmer ce tableau
mais est-ce que vous avez vu l'ensemble
de l'exposition voilà ce qu'elle dit ce
ne sont pas des enfants qui sont
représentés ce tableau traite de la
façon dont la sexualité est utilisée
comme arme de guerre comme crime contre
l'humanité vous avez toute liberté
d'interpréter l'oeuvre comme vous voulez
ce n'est ni à une ministre ni à une
parlementaire en revanche de qualifier
une infraction pénale c'est le rôle de
la justice
alors voilà alors bon ah non mais
attends
c'est un truc de fou et bien sûr
diffuser mais bien sûr ça peut bien dire
c'est un vrai choquant cette œuvre
bouleverse parce que pour moi donc elle
accepte en tout cas
elle accepte elle accepte de réduire un
enfant à une sorte d'esclave sexuelle
alors vous allez me dire mais oui mais
c'est en fait c'est la dénonciation de
non au premier degré cette œuvre elle me
révulse voilà je vous le Daniel pour moi
une oeuf ça doit pas s'expliquer la
ministre a besoin d'un quart d'heure
pour nous expliquer l'intention une
oeuvre qui ne se comprend pas et qui
choque autant on le voit encore là vous
l'avez compris tu l'aurais compris
qui circulent pour moi le message n'est
pas audible cette œuvre est ratée en
tout cas le message
tout de suite quand tu te vois
il y a pas beaucoup d'oeuvre qui sont
qui font penser à de la prison
pornographie après lors de cette oeuvre
là c'était quand même très très spécial
je vous jure que c'est vrai
tu es avec tes enfants je peux dire tu
vois
on s'en fout de l'art moderne est-ce que
tu comprends c'est de la pédophilie on
en a rien à [__] en fait il y a vous
les gens qui comprenaient tout le monde
etc et de crier les gens qui comprennent
les gars alors quand c'est des
manifestants qui brûlent des
design c'est honteux c'est un appareil
etc quand c'est une artiste qui fait de
la petite
qui représente une scène de pédophilie
là c'est formidable c'est une œuvre
d'art pardon c'est pas de l'art c'est de
la merde c'est tout de la merde c'est
dangereux de la merde selon Guillaume
Genton voilà qui a fait des grands noms
mais alors les grandes écoles ont changé
vous êtes avec vos enfants et vous vous
tombez sur ça parce que moi
que l'exposition elle peut choquer donc
si tu sais que les positions pour choqué
après je voudrais Jean-Marie elle a été
très maladroite quand elle a dit vous
pouvez l'interpréter comme vous voulez
justement on doit pas l'interpréter
comme on veut parce que Daniel je sais
pas c'était déjà aller dans un musée ou
pas mais l'oeuvre elle doit pas
s'expliquer d'elle-même c'est bien pour
ça qu'il y a des petits encartes qui
expliquent la vie de l'artiste l'oeuvre
de l'artiste ce qu'il a voulu dire parce
que si j'avance expliquait d'elle-même
et ben quand tu vois un tableau tout
blanc et va tu te dis bah c'est une
sacrée merde non bah non parce que parce
que ça peut coûter très cher parce qu'il
y a des explicatifs
de TPMP vous allez voir c'est un
supportable moi je vais résumer pour
pour tout le monde comme je sais bien le
faire celui qui me dit qu'il ne voit pas
un enfant avec les mains attachés dans
le dos en train de sucer un adulte
celui-là
et puis celui qui m'explique que
derrière tout ça il y a tout un tas de
trucs formidables et ben je l'encule
merci
[Applaudissements]
mais bon alors oui moi je trouve que la
ministre a mille fois raison et je suis
très choqué parce que disent mes
camarades premièrement on a le droit de
trouver une œuvre immonde l'aide
dégueulasse et abject merci on a le
droit de pas aller au palais Tokyo si on
est prévenu si ça nous choque et tout ça
parce que pas est Tokyo c'est l'art
contemporain et l'art content
des bêtises
on se souvient du plug anal place de la
place Vendôme on se souvient du vagin de
la reine
la pédophilie en fait
ça a été critiqué beaucoup on se
souvient aussi du vagin de la reine à
Versailles qui avait été tagué il y
avait même des inscriptions antisémites
dessus donc vous avez la mémoire courte
et troisième raison moi je trouve que en
disant ça tous ceux qui disent oui
faites le jeu des pires tyrannies et des
pirates
bien sûr que s'il te plaît non non non
non
enlever les tablettes
quand il y avait des Noirs dessus ça
devrait te choquer Gilles parce qu'il
disait
il enlève les
salariés
est-ce qu'on peut rappeler je peux
terminer en montrant ça elle témoigne de
l'horreur de la guerre ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui par exemple en Ukraine et en
particulier à bout de chat donc elle est
le témoin aujourd'hui en 2023 d'accord
c'est ce qu'elle veut vous faire penser
vous tombez dans la pièce
elle a fait la guerre de l'Irak elle a
fait toutes les horaires depuis 1990
donc en quoi elle serait suspecte de ça
et encore une fois cette œuvre-là elle
sera le témoin dans 50 ans dans 100 ans
dans 200 ans
que c'est qu'une image
pédopornographique
c'est une scène ou un enfant là dessus
on lui a demandé j'ai pas une [__]
dénigrer
un rapport sexuel avec un adulte pardon
mais on peut rigoler moi demain je vais
dire je vais dire je suis un artiste je
vais prendre une image plus de
pornographie et je veux dire c'est pour
dénoncer parce que tu veux savoir
je suis artiste je vais prendre une
photo pédopornographique je veux dire si
oui c'est pour dénoncer la société de
consommation vous êtes malade crédible
mais vous dites mais vous dites non pas
une photo là c'est une représentation
c'est une représentation de ce qui est
un problème systémique
un problème systémique dans le cadre de
la guerre c'est que les hommes utilisent
le corps des femmes comme une arme de
guerre et bien et là en l'occurrence
c'est ce qu'elle montre elle dit un
enfant c'est une femme elle dit que
c'est une femme une femme elle dit
justement
est-ce que vous avez dit ah mais ils
sont cons autour de la table ils sont
contents de la table mon frère son père
est le seul survivant de sa famille des
grands nucléaires et était une merde
mais le rapprochement est abject là
c'est de la pédo c'est à vomir lui était
un peintre qu'elle parle d'exposer des
tableaux de lui plutôt de lui plutôt que
de revenir sur ses actes pour faire un
vrai débat j'ai compris c'est-à-dire que
c'est une personne a vu le tableau moi
je suis bien sûr
comment je suis dur avec la pédophilie
et Dieu sait ici plusieurs fois vous
m'avez dit il faut pas dire ça c'était
trop dur faut pas condamner comme ça moi
il y a pas de voilà je je verse pas avec
ça là l'auteur du tableau dit que ce
n'est pas un enfant et elle se bat
depuis un branleur
c'est l'intérêt du débat si elle te dit
non
mais moi je m'explique
pas c'est pour ça que je mets non c'est
l'intérêt du débat elle se bat depuis 40
ans contre les viols pendant la guerre
donc si c'est si ça avait été pour
rigoler si ça avait un tableau comme ça
que je parle et que je mets dans un truc
comme ça moi personnellement je
ramènerai pas à mes voir un tableau
comme ça voilà personnellement mais si
elle est le miracle elle le met comme ça
c'est contre la guerre elle n'est pas
pour jouer télécharger des Images pédo
pornographiques sur le net est illégal
allez on admirer au musée c'est autorisé
c'est pas de télécharger
d'une artiste dont le métier dont elle a
plus de 70 ans cette femme ça fait 40
ans qu'elle consacre
ou 35 40 ans que cette femme consacre sa
vie à aller sur les théâtre de guerre et
à le retranscrire alors qu'est-ce que tu
vas dire qu'est-ce que tu dis à Picasso
tu diras Picasso j'en ai rien à [__]
de ton de ton dernier cadeau c'est de la
merde on comprend rien
ce n'est pas du tout la même chose
attaché dans le dos qui suce
toi
je suis désolé comme des milliards je
vois un enfant
de 90 cm s'il vous plaît
Géraldine dit qu'elle dénonçait un truc
donc vous pensez que vous c'est une
femme oui elle le dit d'ailleurs
c'est une femme les mains liées violées
avant d'avoir été tués et jeté
exactement de chaque combat
dégager oui oui franchement je suis
désolé de dire ça mais on est dans un
bar PMU avec des
je suis désolé papa pour toi Cyril mais
quand j'entends par exemple
c'est une émotion un tableau on dénonce
quelque chose un tableau c'est un choc
c'est le finir tableau ce sont ces
choses-là c'est pas juste tu regardes et
tu as compris sinon on fait une voiture
à feu rouge qui s'arrête mais ça fait un
tableau ça c'est un coloriage et puis
parce que c'est ce que tu as dit mais
par ailleurs cette femme quand tu vas
comme la barrière de la Shoah comme j'y
suis allé moins pour les 50 ans
effectivement où il y avait des viols
d'enfants des viols de femmes c'est ce
qu'elle dénonce aussi là-dedans c'est le
principe d'une oeuvre enfin troisième
chose quand on commence à dire ramenez
ça la pédopornographie et Machin comme
tu le fais comme dans ta barbe PMU je
vous rappelle que dans les pays où les
œuvres ont les détruit ou on les juge où
on les interdits ce ne sont pas des
démocraties
et Hitler le faisait vous êtes des tarés
manteau
des petits applaudissements c'est les
chiffres et des lettres
j'ai appris quelque chose c'est qu'en
fait il y a pas que les photos
pédopornographiques c'est-à-dire que
même si c'est par exemple un manga ou
une représentation
pédopornographique c'est qu'est-ce que
tu nous emmerdes
tout le monde voit un enfant
je suis désolé le principe de l'art
c'est d'aider les gens à comprendre
oui à 75% bien sûr
bravo les gens heureusement non
heureusement que vous êtes là c'est bon
c'est bon merci